dans le cadre de la campagne électorale
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine on va
parler des enjeux des attentes des
priorités économiques des canadiens
notre invité ce soir thomas raffy pdg du
conseil économique du nouveau-brunswick
à un manque très rapidement soir bonsoir
est-ce qu'on a parlé est ce qu'on parle
durant cette campagne de vos priorités
économiques
la réponse très courte et non pas assez
en tout cas on parle pas assez des défis
que connaissent les régions la région
atlantique sur sur différents sujets
notamment la question démographique la
question démographique c'est l'enjeu
prioritaire pour vous pour nos membres
qui sont principalement des petites et
moyennes entreprises francophones du
nouveau brunswick
c'est le défi numéro un la question
démographique surtout au niveau bien
évidemment de la main d'oeuvre mais
aussi de façon directe et indirecte la
question démographique de nos
communautés francophones donc
vieillissement de la population
rareté de main-d'oeuvre ce sont les
enjeux principaux exactement il ya aussi
à la question de la main d'oeuvre mais
aussi la question de la relève
d'entreprises qui est très importante
pour nos membres et qui est aussi un
grand défi au niveau au niveau de la
population au niveau de la démographie
jusqu'à quel point le problème est aigu
en ce moment il est tellement aiguë pour
reprendre votre retard mais tellement
aiguë que on anticipe que dans les dix
prochaines années au nouveau brunswick
environ cent vingt mille personnes vont
prendre leur retraite qui est un chiffre
énorme et donc nos entreprises doivent
se tourner principalement vers
l'immigration s'ils ne peuvent pas
recruter des canadiennes et des
canadiens doivent se tourner vers
l'immigration pour aller chercher
combler les postes et assurer la
croissance de leur entreprise et celle
de nos communautés
donc il faut davantage d'immigrants dans
l'est du pays exactement davantage
d'immigrants surtout des immigrants
entrepreneurs aussi pour aider notre
économie pour justement aider nos
communautés et des la croissance de la
province pour le nouveau brunswick et ça
vous l'avez pas entendu depuis le début
de la campagne électorale
on a entendu dans toutes les plateformes
des initiatives des promesses qui sont
axées vers le secteur privé qui sont
axées aussi vers l'immigration mais
vraiment de façon assez large mais quand
il s'agit de parler vraiment de la
région atlantique et des défis que
connaît
nos communautés ici dans les provinces
atlantiques on attend encore plus de
détails à ce niveau le bon est ce que
vous êtes en faveur de la proposition
conservatrice d'aménager un corridor
énergétique qui traverserait le pays
bien sûr jusqu'au nouveau brunswick
je pense que l'idée l'idée très
intéressante parce que le rejoint
vraiment le projet de le fameux projet
énergie est qui n'a pas vu le jour
qui aurait pu avoir des retombées
vraiment intéressante pour notre
province surtout pour nos petites et
moyennes entreprises et aussi au niveau
de la création d'emplois on voit aussi
que dans le projet du parti conservateur
on parle aussi de l'infrastructure de
technologie et justement l'accès à
internet est une promesse qu on entend
très souvent ou du moins à chaque
campagne et qu'il tarde un peu à être
livrées façon très concrète nos régions
sur tout nouveau brunswick que notre
francophonie est quand même une
francophonie rural nouveau brunswick à
environ 47 à 48 % rural et donc si on
veut permettre aux entreprises de
croître et aussi avec des jus personnes
de se lancer en entreprise il faut
s'assurer qu'on est axé principalement à
internet pour permettre pour permettre
des activités cela dit personne n'a
promis de réanimer énergie est durant
cette campagne
non du tout du tout conservateurs et
libéraux proposent des baisses d'impôts
npd verts proposent des hausses d'impôts
pour les entreprises quels sont vos
positions sur ça c'est pas
nécessairement surprenant en connaissant
la philosophie des parties c'est sûr que
nos impôts et nos membres veulent ce
qu'ils sont principalement des
entreprises veulent voir moins d'impôts
la raison la raison est très simple
c'est parce que les coûts d'exploitation
des entreprises ne sont pas en silo
c'est une accumulation de différents
coûts qui repose sur les épaules des
entreprises donc parfois c'est très
difficile à jongler tous ses couleurs ce
qui est vraiment aussi ce qui nous
intéresse encore plus c'est non
seulement ses promesses de diminuer des
impôts ou trouver des façons d'alléger
la charge sur les entreprises mais
c'était aussi de voir des programmes qui
aident à la croissance de l'entreprise
donc pas nécessairement de l'est de les
empêcher de se réduire mais vraiment de
les aider à croître
quels sont les programmes qui vont les
aider au niveau de la main d'oeuvre au
niveau de l'exportation au niveau de la
l'automatisation la robotique qui est
aussi une des solutions aux défis de
lahmada mais en même temps
la part que les gens d'affaires sont
prêts à faire en matière de taxes ou
d'impôts supplémentaires quand on parle
de programmes sociaux importants pour
l'ensemble du canada
on a eu toutes sortes de propositions
sur une hausse de l'imposition du grand
capital des taxes sur la fortune des
taxes sur les biens de luxe
est-ce que les gens d'affaires sont
prêts à en faire un bout là dessus je
pense que les gens d'affaires si vous si
vous les sentez vous disent déjà qu'ils
font déjà leur paraît bien évidemment au
conseil économique on croit que donc on
donne aux entreprises sont justement des
créatrices de richesses parce qu'elle
contribue de différentes façons à faire
leur part et je sais que des quatre
dernières années on a souvent parlé de
cas ce que les entreprises ou du moins
le secteur privé fasse sa juste part et
les définitions sont aussi variées que
que ça mais je pense qu'il y avait quand
même une réalisation il ya quand même
une prise de conscience qui
effectivement pour générer des fonds
pour l'étape pour offrir des services et
surtout quand on parle de vieillissement
de la population on s'attend à ce que
les services liés à un accroissement des
services sur dernier exactement
c'est pour ça que je vous parle d'impôts
et de taxes supplémentaires mais je vais
vous entendre sur la tarification du
carbone taxe carbone tarification du
carbone vous êtes pour vous êtes contre
le nouveau-brunswick a eu une chance
dans les dernières années a présenté son
plan un plan qui a été refusé par le
goût le gouvernement fédéral est donc là
maintenant on s'est retrouvé avec un
plan qui nous a été imposée comme
province quand on parle avec nos membres
la question et il ya certainement
beaucoup d'entre eux sont contre la taxe
carbone et mais principalement pour le
fait que la question qui se pose
vraiment et quelle est l'intention de
cette taxe l'intention est de changer
les comportements inciter les canadiens
à avoir adopté des comportements qui
sont plus responsables envers
l'environnement
est ce qu'on nous a imposée au nouveau
brunswick ce nous amène à la question
est-ce que ça a vraiment amène un
changement de comportement les mêmes et
25 dollars la tonne ça change pas les
comportements mais quand on sera rendu
plus haut possiblement exactement mais
au nouveau brunswick ce que nous avons
principalement ce sont des petites et
moyennes entreprises et donc par
conséquent pas des grands émetteurs au
niveau des gaz à effet de serre mais
celles ci ont besoin d'appui et dead
pour investir justement dans des
équipements dans des procédures qui vont
te qui vont les aider à prendre le
virage vert donc
ce que nous entendons souvent sur le
terrain c'est quelles sont les mesures
ou quel est le message qu'on peut
envoyer à celles et ceux qui font et
quand je parle de celles et ceux sont
les entreprises les entrepreneurs qui
font les démarches et qui vont justement
prendre le temps de le faire au lieu
d'aller chercher a pénalisé par par
cette taxe la quille mais ne cherche pas
nécessairement à changer les
comportements
messieurs les filles merci beaucoup pour
cet entretien merci à vous